The only way to be truly satisfied
Is to do what you believe is great work.
And the only way to do great work
is to love what you do.
If you haven't found it yet, keep looking
and don't settle. As with
all matters of the heart,
you'll know when you find it.
Sometimes life is gonna hit you
in the head with a brick.
Don't lose faith
I'm convinced that the only thing
that kept me going is that
I loved what I did
You've got to find what you love
So you have to trust that the dots
will somehow connect in your future
You have to trust in something,
your gut, destiny, life, karma, Whatever
because believeing that the dots
will connect down the road
will give you the confidence
to follow your heart
even when it leads you off
the well worn path
and that will make all the difference.
Your time is limited, so
don't waste it living someone else's life.
Don't be trapped by dogma
which is living with the results of
other people's thinking
Don't let the noise of others
opinions drown out your own inner voice
And most important have the courage
to follow your heart and intuition
They somehow already know what you truly
want to become. Everything else
is secondary.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community